on en revient à la situation sanitaire
en russie où le nombre de nouveaux
cadeaux qu'ovide repart à la hausse
après une baisse progressive enregistrée
depuis novembre les autorités sanitaires
vont jusqu'à craindre de nouveaux
records en raison la souche mikron ont
fait le point tout de suite avec notre
correspondante à moscou maylis
déstresser la propagation du variant au
micro les autorités sanitaires russes se
montrent pessimistes
d'après elle si la situation ne
s'améliore pas le pays pourrait être
prochainement dépasser les cent mille
contamination quotidienne contre environ
17000 500 recensés ce mardi alors que
305 cadiot variant au micro ont déjà été
détectés dans plusieurs régions du pays
le premier ministre appelle à se
préparer au pire 8 octobre 2006
nous constatons que la situation dans le
monde se détériore rapidement notamment
dans certains pays d'amérique d'asie et
d'europe tout d'abord en raison de la
propagation d'une nouvelle souche il est
important d'être préparés à toute
évolution de la situation après les
vacances de nouvel an beaucoup de gens
rentrent chez eux y compris depuis
l'étranger il faut prendre cela en
compte l'ensemble des mesures pour
contrer l'infection reste le même
c'est à moscou principal foyer de
l'épidémie que la situation est la plus
préoccupante
ce mardi le nombre de nouveaux cas et a
grimpé de 67 % en 24 heures une
augmentation due à omicron selon le
maire de la capitale
ce qui nous préoccupe comme vous l'avait
bien dit c'est que nous suivons ce qui
se passe dans les pays voisins et nous y
constatons une flambée de contamination
sur fond de la nouvelle souche omicron à
moscou malheureusement nous constatons
déjà un très grand nombre de personnes
infectées précisément par omicron ce
nombre ce pourcentage ne cesse
d'augmenter
cela signifie que nous nous trouvons
également dans une zone à risque et que
à mon avis nous devrions faire face à
une croissance importante du taux de
contamination
ces sept à dix jours à venir
s'ils me disent tu signé à doha jusqu'au
bout des meubles des machines
les autorités russes soulignent que le
vaccin reste le moyen le plus fiable
pour lutter contre l'épidémie leur
vaccination avec spoutnik vais
protégerait d'ailleurs également contre
mikron d'après le ministre de la santé
aujourd'hui plus de 10% de la population
du pays a reçu la troisième dose du
vaccin sur près de 50 % des russes ayant
reçu deux doses